(vehicle engine revving)
- [Mark] Okay, Vicky.
- Yes.
- [Mark] Vicky, where
are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- I was born in Culver City, I
was born in Brotman Hospital.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood,
you grew up with both your parents?
- [Vicky] No, I only grew up with my mom.
- [Mark] Just your mum?
- [Vicky] Yeah.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- It was okay until my
brother molested me.
- [Mark] At what age?
- At 12.
- [Mark] At 12?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Older brother?
And it was behind,
him and his friend actually,
they both did something to me.
They were playing Spin the bottle,
I don't know if you've heard of that.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And me, I didn't know
anything I was young.
- [Mark] How old were you?
- I was only 12.
So my brother spins the...
I guess his friend spins the bottle
and the bottle lands on his friend.
So, he tells his friend
to take me in the bathroom
and for me to suck his dick.
Sorry, I'm saying that.
- [Mark] Okay.
- But and then it was my
brother's turn to get spinned
and it landed on him, the bottle,
and his friend told him,
"I dare you to go in the
bathroom and have sex with her"
and that's just what he did.
And he continued until
maybe 13, 14.
I finally let it out when I was,
I'm 39 years old,
I let it out,
(car rumbles nearby)
it finally came out to the
light when I was about 35,
about four years ago.
And I don't have no
relationship with him no more,
because the truth came out
and he's in denial of it.
- [Mark] So you never even
talked about it until 35?
- Yeah, I kept it all, I
kept it inside until then,
I didn't tell anybody.
- [Mark] Your mum never found out?
- No.
I told my mom before she died
and my thing is that if I was lying,
I wouldn't remember partial
things of what happened
and after this game was done,
after that, after he did what
he did, he continued to do it.
We would go in the closet.
He would tell me, "you can't tell nobody",
the blanket we would use would be green.
And things like that you don't remember,
if you're lying you're not
gonna remember none of that.
It's always gonna affect you
and me it does, and it
actually affected my kids.
My kids were molested by
their father, two of them.
And now one of them that was molested,
she keeps running away and
now they can't find her.
- [Mark] How old is she?
- 16.
This happened, now this is the
third time that I know about.
The second time that I found about was,
the police called me from Fontana
and they told me, have I
seen my daughter, Sandra?
and I told them, "No",
they said, "She's missing"
and I had already felt that,
because my sister sent me a text message
about my daughter wanting
to go to her house
and stay with her for a couple of days.
When my sister responded to
me about it she asked me,
"What's going on with Sandra?"
and I said, "I don't know,
"I haven't been able to
get in contact with her".
She tells me, "She
Instagrammed me and told me
"that she wanted to come and
stay for a couple of days.
"And when I responded to her,
"her file was deleted.
"There was nothing, her
Facebook is deleted".
When my sister messaged, when
she Facebooked me a message,
sending me that message,
I knew from then something was wrong.
When the police called me,
after the police called me
and they gave me all the information,
my daughter called me
and told me that they picked her up
and they took her home and
my daughter was lying to me.
And again, she did the
same thing all over again,
she did it the day before they called me
and then she did it again
the day that they called me
and now she's at it again.
My thing is, is that,
me I don't think my
daughter is running away
just for nothing.
Me I think my daughter's
running away for a reason.
Somebody is doing something to her
and she doesn't know what to
do, just like her dad did.
- [Mark] Just like with you?
- Yeah.
And they say that, when it happens to,
it how do you say that it...
It goes on to the next generation.
If I was molested, my kids are...
I mean, something's gonna
happen like that to my kids.
Yeah.
- [Mark] And she's 16?
- Yeah.
And my other daughter
she's been in trouble with the law
behind what's happened to her.
Because
she lets people get away
with doing things to her
and it built up so bad
to where she almost did
it really, really badly.
She gave a girl a concussion
because the girl wouldn't even know
about things that were going on with her,
that happened to her.
Somehow in their school,
it got around to what
happened to my girls.
And my daughter,
she'll take as much as she
can until she explodes.
And she exploded and she got in trouble.
She had to be on probation.
She...
They got kicked out of the
school that they were in.
- [Mark] Where do your daughters--
- My family.
- [Mark] They stay with your mom?
- Yeah.
Their father was deported.
He's not from here. He's Mexican.
And he was deported behind doing this.
- [Mark] For real?
- [Vicky] Yeah.
Me, I'm a victim of domestic violence,
physically, mentally, for 17 plus years
behind him.
He's done a really lot of things
and I'm not saying I'm perfect,
it goes both ways.
But he's threatened to
kill me and my kids.
I've even tried to
commit suicide to myself.
I cut... I'm what they call a cutter.
And I'm out here on the streets.
I had everything, everything was good.
Behind him and him doing what he did,
which is lewd acts on a
child under the age of 14,
we lost everything.
I had a job, I had everything.
I had everything good.
And now I can't even get help.
I can't get help for sheltering,
for victims of domestic violence,
for mental problems.
And for counseling.
I called this place to get help
to get support and
everything they answered.
They returned my call.
They told me they were
gonna return my call
after the holidays.
You think they ever did? No.
I've been trying to get help out here
and it's not easy.
- [Mark] And you're living on the street?
- [Vicky] Yeah.
- [Mark] How long you
been out here in Skid Row?
- [Vicky] Probably about
four, five years now.
But I don't do like what
everybody else does.
I smoke weed, yeah,
But that's about it.
- [Mark] You don't do any hard--
- No.
I used to.
I was 17 plus years clean.
I got sober and clean.
After what happened to
me, I went to drugs.
Like what my brother did
to me, I went to drugs.
I was smoking crack.
I started smoking crack when I was
almost 13.
And me, I stopped for 17
years and I stopped by myself.
I did it (mumbles) by myself
and no program or nothing.
Me I can't be on the streets
and do that because it's...
- [Mark] Why are you not
at home with your kids?
- My kids because,
like I said, I have to
get the help that I need.
I was court ordered because of what I...
Because I tried to commit suicide,
to get help, get
counseling and everything.
I can't even, you know what?
I get GR, I don't get cash.
I can't even afford to take
out my driver's license
because I don't get no cash.
I only get food stamps.
So it's kinda hard on me.
And if I don't have an ID,
nobody wants to help you.
My ID is expired.
They don't want to help you.
- [Mark] Is your mom still alive?
- No, my mom's deceased.
I actually told my mom, maybe
five months before she died
about what my brother did to me.
And me, I was willing to
take a lie detector test
and everything.
And nothing was ever said.
I told my mother, "Since he didn't..."
Since he was lying and
saying that I'm a liar,
I said, "I'll take a lie detector test.
"I'll go on "The Steve Wilkos
Show", if you want me to...
"And I'll tell you there.
"And it'll come out."
- [Mark] Do you see
the connection between
what happened to you--
- And what happened to my kids, yeah.
- [Mark] Where you are today
and where your kids are today?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you think any of that stuff
would have happened now
if that hadn't happened,
when you were young?
- If it wouldn't have happened to me,
no, I don't think it would have.
- [Mark] Changes your life, really.
- Yeah, a lot.
And being out here changes my life too.
And I want to get off the
streets so bad, but it's hard.
It's hard 'cause I go for help.
Answer I get is, "Call shelters."
I call 'em, I don't get no answer.
I go to places,
"Oh, we can't help you 'cause
you don't have a driver...
"You don't have an ID."
What's wrong with using
my Social Security Number?
That's my identity too.
I know they don't accept that either.
And my driver's license can be expired.
The only one is that,
the one that I have
right now is (mumbles),
and it's expired and
they don't accept that.
- [Mark] It's hard on
where you live (mumbles)?
- Yeah it is.
I'm not used to this.
Like me I would stay up for days,
'cause I'm not used to sleeping in a tent.
I probably slept in two tents.
This is the second time
that I slept in with...
I mean, it's cause the reason why
is you don't know what can happen.
Somebody could do something,
somebody rob somebody
and they can come out
and take it after you're out off,
if you're with that person,
you know what I mean?
Yeah, I've heard stories.
I've heard people telling me about,
how somebody got them for their money
and they grabbed their tent
and they got a chain
and they dragged it with
the people in the tent,
things like that.
I've seen things.
I've seen a man drive down this block
and a man was hanging on
the outside of his car,
talking about, "Give me my money."
I've seen a lot of things.
And it's kind of scary.
I'm not used to things like that.
- [Mark] They are just some
horrible things (mumbles),
if you really know what's going on.
- Yeah.
Especially if you're not
used to things like this.
I mean, living in South Central
it's bad, but here it's...
South Central in downtown LA,
they don't got nothing on each other.
South Central's a little
bit better than this.
- [Mark] This is another world.
- [Vicky] Yeah (chuckles).
Yeah, for real is.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Well, Vicky, thank
you so much for talking to me.
- You're welcome.
Thank you for hearing my story.
- [Mark] Yeah, and good
luck with everything
and your kids too.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Thanks.